la maison elsa triolet aragon ne cesse
de se renouveler
autrefois propriété de deux écrivains
elsa triolet et louis aragon la maison
musée propose désormais des visites
commentées individuel de son jardin
dédié à ses sculptures
l'objectif partagé discuter et découvrir
les nombreuses oeuvres contemporaines
répartis sur ce parc de 6 hectares
aragon et elsa triolet donc c'était deux
écrivains très curieux de toutes les
autres formes d'art donc on le voit dans
leur mise on voit aussi dans ce parc
en fait il s'intéressait à tout ce qui
était possible de faire avec l'art et
arabes ont ou peu de temps après la mort
d'anna triolet quand il fera don de
cette maison à l'état voudra que ça
continue voilà qu'il pique nique on
continue à accueillir dans cette
création artistique
un souhait respecté par l'association
qui gère désormais le musée elle s'est
d'ailleurs donné trois vocations la
recherche la mémoire et la promotion de
l'art contemporain
avec cette visite vous fait donc un
parcours nous présente aux personnes
déjà le lien qui existe entre aragon et
la création contemporaine
justement avec ce souhait est aussi donc
ça nous permet de te parler un peu de
ses oeuvres d'artistes qu'on a exposé
aussi nous de leur faire découvrir plein
d'aspects de l'art contemporain parce
qu'en fait il n'y a pas juste certaines
cultures on aborde beaucoup de types
d'art notamment le street art l'art
minimaliste au fil des années de
nombreuses oeuvres se sont rajoutés à la
collection parmi elles celle de
l'artiste jef aérosol christophe chabot
neil et nos bus comme watanabe pour
découvrir toutes ces oeuvres le musée
propose des visites d'une heure de
février à novembre